-Dan, have you ever seen
anything like this
in your career?
-No, Jimmy, I have not.
You know, I've been blessed
to live this long.
I'm 89 years old,
and I've seen a few things
over the years,
including the Great Depression,
World War II, Watergate, 9/11 --
so many things.
I've never seen
anything like this.
You know, my reaction, I think,
was the most common reaction
of the day.
I cannot believe
that I'm seeing this.
I can't believe
I'm watching this.
As I believe you mentioned
somewhere along the way,
it was like watching
a very bad horror movie --
horror movie for our country.
-Yeah.
-And, no, I've never seen
anything like this before.
And neither has any other
American, thank God.
And let us hope
we never see it again.
-The last I heard is that
the Senate wanted to go back in
as soon as they can
and continue and get the count.
What happens now with the vote?
-Well, what happens now,
I would say, Jimmy, having
talked as we have seriously
about what happened today
with the mob violence
and the mob storming
into the Capitol,
history is going to record --
Today's big headlines are,
sometime late tonight
or sometime tomorrow,
the Biden election
is going to be certified
by the Congress.
The Congress is gonna
have their vote,
certifying
the Electoral College vote,
and Joe Biden will be
officially, formally,
the new president-elect
of the United States,
and Kamala Harris will be
the new vice president-elect.
That's going to be --
You know, that's set.
And history will record that
as the big headline.
The second headline is that
the Democrats are gonna control
the Senate, if these results
in Georgia hold,
and this is the way it looks.
There are gonna be two new
Democratic Senators in Georgia.
And, you know, this --
this is a whole new day
for the country.
In 13 days,
we have a new president,
new vice president, and if
the Georgia results hold,
which I expect they will,
this Senate will be controlled
by the Democrats,
since Kamala Harris
has the swing vote.
It's going to be a new day
for the country.
And those who took part in
storming the Capitol today,
history will footnote them, but
it will footnote them in shame.
The real people, the real heroes
of this democracy today
are, one, my old friend,
the late John Lewis,
Ms. Abrams,
Stacey Abrams in Georgia,
and all those people who,
in the runoff election,
in both parties,
did what they're supposed to do.
They knocked on doors to take
part in a Democratic process.
And once the count, the final
count's in, they accept it.
These are the heroes
of this day.
These people
who've shamed themselves
and shamed our country
by storming our Capitol
and going inside and taking part
in violence inside the Capitol
are the ones that should be
shamed today, and that's --
that really should be
the news of the day.
Unfortunately, we're gonna be
distracted for some time
by this nastiness
that happened at the Capitol.
-Do you think Trump
really believes that he --
the election was rigged, or does
he have a different agenda?
-I do not.
I will say,
"How could I know what's in
Donald Trump's heart?"
I don't.
And the straight answer
to your question, I think he
knows exactly what he's doing.
I think he knows he lost.
He's the quintessential
poor loser.
I think he, all along,
took the attitude,
"If I don't win the vote,
then I'm gonna try to make sure
that nobody accepts
the honest vote."
I think he's known
what he's doing all along.
I think he knows
what he's doing now,
and I think he's feeling
very good about himself,
because today,
he got the whole headlines,
the whole attention,
all came to him and his movement
away from the fact that Biden
had won the election
and that two new
Democratic Senators
had been elected in Georgia,
apparently,
and the Democrats
will control the Senate.
So I think he's feeling
pretty good about himself
at this moment.
-What's next
for President-elect Biden?
He has to unite the country.
How does he do that?
How do we move forward
as a country?
What's at stake here?
-Well, what's at stake
is the very future
of the United States of America.
You know, we have had
the world's most successful
democratic government, the most
successful democratic government
in the history of the world,
that ours is
a constitutional republic
based on the principles
of freedom and democracy.
The question has always been,
"Can we hold ourselves
together?"
And that is the major challenge
of the Biden administration,
and it's no small challenge,
because well over 75 million,
76 million Americans
voted for Donald Trump.
And trying to re-establish
some normal amount of unity
in a country,
in a situation we're in now,
is a tremendous challenge
for President Biden.
I do think he has to make
the decision pretty early
whether he is to be
a transitional president
or a transformational president.
That is, is he just gonna be
sort of a president
who re-established some norms
but just was waiting
for the next president
to be really transformative,
or is he gonna try to be
a transformational president?
A lot of that depends
on what happens
with those
within the Republican Party.
How many of those
in the Republican Party
hold on to the Trump fantasy and
try to keep Trumpism in control,
or do they take their party
in a different direction?
But the challenge for Biden
right away is to decide
and to act upon
whether he's transitional
or whether he's just a
transformational president.
-Dan, I thank you for
all the years of your work
in journalism, and I also want
to thank you for your tweets,
because they are calming
in a lot of this craziness
that's surrounding us.
And I thank you again for being
on our program tonight.
-I really appreciate that,
Jimmy.
I would like to leave it
on an up note,
and I think we should.
You know, we all sang or used to
sing "God Bless America."
"God bless America,
stand beside her and guide her
through the night with the light
from above and from within."
We might not sing it tonight,
but we might want to hum it
and just play the words over
in our head,
because if we hold steady,
we're gonna be okay.
-My thanks to Dan Rather.
You can see season eight
of his show,
"The Big Interview,"
Wednesdays at 8:00 p.m.,
on Access TV.